what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
hello everybody and welcome back
with your favorite sister sophie and
sistine stallone if you're new
welcome if you're back welcome back that
was kind of a weird intro honestly
i think you tried to not say it this
time but your mouth
literally wouldn't let you no you know
it's just a thing that you guys
love to look forward to i think it's a
nervous tic no it's not a nervous tic
i'm not nervous on this podcast anymore
i'm ready for it but guys
guess what's coming up thanksgiving
gobble gobble baby
dabble gobble and i turkey season
it will have already happened that's
true oh that's right that's right by the
time this episode airs
thanksgiving would have already happened
and i know that sistine i talked about
it uh a couple of days ago but she
you said you didn't love thanksgiving
it's not your favorite holiday i like to
say
it's one of mine but not for reasons
i don't like thanksgiving that's how i
don't mean i don't love the
the aspect that we get to be with family
and friends
and and look at all the things we're
thankful for i love that i'm all gushy
mushy about that [ __ ]
tell me what's wrong with family food
did you not just listen to what i said i
said i liked that there's nothing wrong
with family
food or something what's the wrong
what's wrong with it
a few things one don't love the food
i'll tell you why
a few years ago i got stomach flu on
thanksgiving so the turkey doesn't sit
well with me anymore you probably over
ate
stomach flu how is that possible stomach
flu did you
yes i did you were downstairs drinking
having a blast while i was up facing the
toilet
number two i really didn't care
obviously yeah no one helped me holiday
very lonely thanksgiving i was committed
to the holiday
number two i don't love cooking
i don't love it i like to bake i just
don't like cooking no one actually
thinks that i can contribute in my
family because i do end up messing up a
lot of it
accurate so number three so i just get
yelled at so number three
i don't like the fact that everyone
comes home for thanksgiving
especially your exes thanksgiving let me
tell you thanksgiving is like yikes
the ghosts of past come to haunted
especially you
especially me because i have a lot of
ghosts i would die actually every time
sistine's facetime goes off it's one of
her ex's
especially this season i know because
let me tell you something not christmas
you don't hear from them all year all of
a sudden they're home for thanksgiving
they're like
what's good shoddy they don't say that
they don't say that but they say
would love to catch up get some dinner
how about no
and then i have to stand inside going um
can you just watch their story to see if
they're in town or not
[Laughter]
just one just one but you know i i can
understand that because i don't have
that problem i love it because
i love to cook i love watching football
i love watching dog shows
i love the food oh yes the dog show we
love the dog show
you get mashed potatoes i don't like
turkey i love ham
the honey glazed ham that we get we're
gonna keep sofia away from the mashed
potatoes
this year oh sophia has okay
i'm going to tell you this we're calling
it mashed potato gate 2018. this is the
problem all right
um if you guys don't understand what
christine's talking about now you will
um
so i used to always be in charge of the
mashed potatoes
every single year was my favorite i
don't know if it was just because it's
super easy to make mashed potatoes but
everyone eats them everyone loves them
and they're just a winner overall so one
year it was last year or is the year
before that
two years two years ago yeah i've been
relieved from my mashed potato mashed
potato making duties that was a tongue
twister um
i was putting it in the oven just so it
would
reheat and like stay warm and i put tin
foil over i put it in a ceramic bowl it
was not that hot
don't worry i'm not like blowing up the
house or anything so dinner started
and i took out the bowl from the oven
and i
dropped it on the ground the side of it
and so when it fell over all the mashed
potatoes still landed on the
um the what's it called the covering the
the tin foil yeah so it didn't hit the
ground so let me take another
maybe a normal person would say oh god
potatoes splattered all over the floor
let's throw it away
not us not us five second rule save the
floor
scoop it back in we don't let food waste
scoop it back down who would argue with
that
exactly so too much work you can't make
all those potatoes again
it was a giant bowl that was like twice
the size of my body so
we're hands and knees so i'm shoving it
back
back and i'm like oh my god i ruined
thanksgiving this is like the only thing
everyone eats
so i'm putting it in put it in the
ceramic bowl and i should put it on the
table like okay we're good everything
looks good i looked around
everything's good we're sitting at the
table no one says everything anything
everyone's eating
and cut to like two hours later we're
all cleaning in the kitchen
and this woman's wife comes up and this
woman's wife oh sorry this man's wife
comes up thank you
and says um which one of you made the
mashed potatoes
and i go me i did
and she goes well my husband
was eating them and pulled out a three
inch pointy sharp piece of ceramic
from the mashed potatoes out of his
mouth and he almost swallowed it
and she i i was speechless i felt
i didn't even know it but let me make
the story even better
it wasn't just some regular old joe
schmo
that swallowed this around i mean look
we would care if it was a regular joshua
but this was uh
but this happened to be a starting
player
for the rams the rams football team have
you heard of him
starting play starting player we won't
say his position your fantasy league
would have been destroyed by me
sophia almost killed an nfl athlete on
thanksgiving
and he didn't say anything yeah he was
so nice but his wife just had a child
and she was looking me going you almost
killed basically the father of my
children
you almost killed the entire rams team
you almost killed my husband
and um from then on out my whole family
said
you were never allowed to cook anything
so now my duties
are putting vegetables in the oven
roasting them and taking it out
yes that is the time i almost killed an
nfl player on thanksgiving
thank you i'm gonna call you out too um
to change it up why
you went on chat roulette again this
woman has an addiction
to chat roulette why are you doing this
because my omegle wasn't working
oh what do you mean what did you
discover on there
well a lot of wieners oh
geez no no you know she's like
fulfilled done you know honestly i had a
lot of fun
i had a lot of fun not not the wiener
part but just
chatting with some strangers i just like
to talk to weird people like i just like
to you would be much too scared to do it
and scarlett was like i'm not going to
be i heard
this feels weird it was weird the
funniest though is there's this one girl
and she was playing a saxophone in her
room she's just like jamming out playing
soccer
i like the vibe this is cool right so
then i am in the camera i'm doing this
i'm dancing i'm like
vibing out to the to the socks she comes
up to the camera and she goes
gives me the strangest look she goes you
need help and then
hangs up on me i was like brat what a
brag you're playing sacks alone on chat
roulette i need help
okay lady she's like creeper watching me
play sax
i know just absolutely boggled my mind
boggling
anyway today we have a very exciting
guest on i love this guest because she's
my friend i get to call her a new friend
and
actually if you guys recall from the
last episode and we were talking about
how to make friendships and putting
yourself out there blah blah and i gave
an example of a girl
that reached out to me and said hey i
think we should be friends let's get
lunch
and she's on the show and she's on the
show so steen's been talking about her
tv i haven't met her yet so i'm really
excited to finally meet her no but she's
so cool she has you know a huge youtube
following instagram falling ticked out
like she's
she's killing it on all the platforms
she's so much fun you guys are gonna
love her and we have so many exciting
topics to go over it's gonna be fun girl
chat
so stay tuned when i say hello you say
fresh
hello fresh hello fresh let's go baby
get fresh pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
with hellofresh america's number one
meal kit hellofresh lets you skip those
long and tiresome trips to the grocery
store and makes home cooking
easy fun and affordable not only that
hellofresh offers convenient no contact
delivery to your doorstep
for easy home cooking with the family
feeding the whole family has never been
easier with lower prices for larger box
sizes
some more servings means more savings
hello fresh delivers fresh high quality
and pre-portioned ingredients so you can
make the meals that are delicious
and nutritious i love that hellofresh is
the first
global carbon neutral meal kit company
by skipping the grocery store and using
hello fresh you're reducing your food
waste
to 25 people that's crazy my mind is
blown keep your fridge stocked by adding
extra meals
or additional proteins quick meals like
breakfast on the go
or their 10 minute lunches and even
desserts to satisfy that sweet tooth
and not only that hellofresh is
committed to donating to those in need
so so far in 2020 guys they have donated
3.5
million meals that's incredible so if
you want to get in on this deal go to
hellofresh.com
unlocks90 and use code on wax90 to get
ninety dollars off
including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com slash on wax90
and use code on wax90 to get ninety
dollars off including free shipping
hello fresh baby
you're so cute that's the perfect intro
welcome you guys ladies and gentlemen
today
we have a guest that needs no
introduction her personality says it all
aside from being you know an incredible
karen knightley impersonator
amazing she has a successful youtube
channel tick tock instagram
etc all the platforms i'm very lucky to
call this person my
friend we have a new cat mom and bad
bleep
olivia royer
[Applause]
oh baby baby gonna do it
okay thank you for coming on thank you
i'm nervous and i have period cramps
i love it you love it see this is why i
love olivia and i don't know if you know
this but the last
episode you said you listened to a
little bit of it no i listened to the
whole thing thank you i literally was
so like when you were like oh my god it
was so nice when she messaged me being
like let's hang out
i was so excited that you responded and
i
knew
that you wanted to think about you this
is so sweet yes
she knew yeah because no one reaches out
to you
except this one no no no in the email
that you were showing me yesterday where
it talked about like
what we're going to talk about it said
at the top they mentioned olivia in the
last thing
so i listened to it and i was like what
did they say
she's the worst friend she forces her to
go to the gym
she's so bad she's the one who's not
gonna bring her on and just
roast her worse but you mentioned you
guys this is olivia's first podcast
yeah it's my podcast virginity we're
breaking it we popped that podcast
she's getting cramps yes i'm getting
cramps from it no but
i want to talk about your forwardness
with like friendships because you're so
good at it oh thank you
but you also mentioned you were
homeschooled i did online school for my
last year and a half of school and you
grew up in texas and then you moved to
l.a did you sort of force yourself to
you know reach out and be friends with
people no it was quite the opposite i
feel like i've
never had good luck with friends and so
i just i was different that's such a
cliche to say but i feel like you know
that's one
thing like no one really liked me
because i had my youtube and i like
didn't want to be there
outfitted what i mean i mean what year
did you decide to do online school
um i was probably 16 my junior year and
then i did uh
a year and a half online and finished a
semester earlier
you did the toughest years in person
yeah school freshman and sophomore and i
was like i'm out of here
yeah is that when you moved to l.a you
stayed in texas um i stayed in texas
until i turned 18 and when i turned 18.
i moved out here and i had
no friends for the longest time and then
i think um
acting class made me get out of my shell
and be like oh i i'm fine being myself
and
being weird and whatever i sit down it
just got me so much more comfortable
with myself and with like
you know reaching out to people who i
can tell have like good energy and good
vibes like i don't reach out to a lot of
people being like let's get lunch like i
hate going to lunch with someone who you
just [ __ ]
you're like what is the point yeah why
are we going to lunch wasted an hour
it's
it's just pointless how are you trying
to like you want to do youtube and
you're killing it in that area and you
also want to act
so do you find that youtube is helping
you um
it's kind of a double-sided coin and
it's something i think about a lot
because it
while it's amazing and it's got me to
where i am today and it's like
gave given me the ability to pay for
myself and
be financially independent and um you
know not have to work in nine to five
while pursuing acting
it's also the other side of the coin
where it's like
i don't want to ever walk into an
audition room and they're like oh she's
a youtuber
yeah we don't want to have someone who's
like known for doing youtube in the
project because it like
yeah some people you know there's people
who do youtube and social media then
they go into acting and everyone's like
you suck get out of here yeah i want to
take
yeah i want to be taken seriously as an
actor so it's like
it's kind of a hard coin i want it to
keep growing and i want to keep doing my
youtube because i love it but i'm also
like
i acting is what i really want to do and
i hope it doesn't tinder
you know i think it's just a weird
generational thing because
i mean the people that are casting you
in these in these roles
did not have the youtube and they don't
understand this way
the way that kids are making money today
so but i also think it it helps in a lot
of weird ways and it does in the
background strange yeah
we see a lot of these girls like addison
ray and all these chicks are getting
huge roles yeah uh he's all that he's
all that which is like one of my
favorite
90s films i'm so excited the 80s 90 i
think it's 90s but like
she got that and she did i think youtube
or tick tock first
so it does help i think just make sure
you're good
yeah i mean is like no it's true the
proof is in the pudding like if
if i book something whether it be
because the number of followers i have
or whatever it is like
and if i'm worried about people being
like oh you suck and you shouldn't act
if the proof is in the pudding if i get
up there and i'm good then people will
be like okay she's good and she's good
it doesn't matter if she's a youtuber
you know
you can give someone [ __ ] for so long
and like as many times as they want if
they're still making money and they're
still doing well like
who's winning who's winning at the same
time um i want to transition a little
bit we're going to talk about
how when i met you you're in a
relationship i was and now
[Music]
hi welcome to the club oh beautiful how
long were you dating this person before
uh a year and a half uh okay a long time
yeah yes moment of silence for the
relationship
thank you thank you thank you so much
it's it's been up and down
since then it's obviously hard dealing
with a breakup but you were telling me
this funny story about
how olivia's following is like such a
cult like loyal group of people
like they really are like it's honestly
incredible like i'm very jealous of that
i wish i had that you know it's really
do all my recon and everything for me
like one of your followers sort of
screenshotted
something from your ex on a certain app
oh yeah
care to explain yeah i got multiple dms
because i don't really talk about my
relationships on social media
um i think it's just a part i like to
keep private but
you know people obviously notice when
people stop liking pictures or like when
you're not seen together anymore or
whatever it is and
i think after like the first three weeks
after being broken up i got like
four dms that day being like hey just
want to let you know like
um i saw your boyfriend on
tinder i don't know if it's a fake
profile it totally could be
but like just want to let you know and
in my head i'm like no he's single
that's definitely him that is
so funny thank you i had the same
experience but she was my person that
found it
how was oh right i found sophia's ex on
ryan oh yeah and it was like
how long after like maybe did i match
yes
he's like the oldest is getting too old
let's go for the youngest if i attracted
you
call me he's going through the sisters i
know right through next okay
what do you what was like the first
thing that came to your head oh man
i was like it was so hard because there
was part of me who
that was like i broke up with him so i
get it like he has
the right to go do this yeah but it also
just kind of like
it it stings yeah you're like oh my god
like what wait first of all i'm not
going out and hooking up with people or
like on tinder or anything like that
not for me right but are you happy on
the flip side that you had these like
loyal followers oh yeah have your back
or do you kind of wish that you just
never knew
i feel like i would have known either
way like you could just assume you know
what i mean i feel like it's better
to know and like someone sent me a
screenshot of his actual like bio and
the pictures he had
on twitter and i was like i just kind of
looked at it and i was like
wait were the photos of photos that you
like you've taken it thank god no
it wasn't photos i'd taken of him
well one of them was like a photo of me
but like crocodile was the crop
oh i hope she finds this
hope she does it yeah i burned but you
know it's like i've had the same thing
like we ended
i ended it but you don't really know
what to do because you're like i don't
want you to get over me
yeah you're like you're like hold on
it's been three weeks and you're on
tinder and i'm sitting here
crying what what is going on i get
you're trying to move on yeah
that's a theory i feel like the way that
men and women break up is so different
women right after the breakup they
grieve it for like
three months let's say or maybe less
whatever three months we'll say
and you're crying and you're sad and you
can't move on and then after three
months
you're chilling you're cruising for the
rest of your life yeah men
first three months post breakup they
sort of were like hell yeah
i'm single and then
month four comes and they're like oh
[ __ ] i miss my ex real bad
yeah they get in their fields and i'm
not saying this is all men all women but
the ones that i've experienced i find
that to be the case well they end up
coming back right when you're moving on
you're like oh god yeah well
well do you agree with this i was just
about to say you've described the
healthy way to deal with something and
the unhealthy way to do it
okay just go through your emotions or
bury them so you go through your
emotions
yes very much proud of you that's good
but well's like a
really decent human being grew up with a
lot of like
strong women in my life so i'm like i
like talking about my feelings yeah we
love feelings
i have another theory as to why guys
quickly go on dating
because like the validation especially
if like after a breakup they're like oh
this girl doesn't the ego
yeah the ego they need even if they're
not meeting up with these girls to them
it's like oh i'm on this dating app and
people are swiping right on me so i'm
attractive
or like they're messaging me so there's
interest for me even though my ex
doesn't have it anymore for them it's
like an ego even if they never go
through with
meeting up with the girls right it still
feels nice to get a
heart a match uh yeah a message being
like you cute or whatever
you know what i mean i still got it yeah
i am on it for that reason
i feel like invasive when i see them on
a dating app i'm like oh god like i know
i'm not supposed to see i know you're
seeing me at this point but like
it kind of feels like you do you stalk
olivia because sophia and i have
incredible stalking abilities oh yes i
was
i do oh what's your methods
um so i have a i have like my actual
instagram account and then i have like a
random user that yeah it's like user
to something like just the most random
thing i just follow everyone who i don't
want to follow on my personal account
there
and i use it to like go watch x's
stories like or figure out who they're
following
or like whatever it is if you knew that
this girl had a fake account would it
would you be like that's kind of creepy
it depends on how the breakup went uh
you know what i mean
like i broke up with somebody that like
i genuinely cared about so i didn't like
breaking up with them but i knew it
wasn't right for me
and then those feelings really like hung
around for a minute so i was like oh
they're still there so yeah
okay but if it was like if they were
like a [ __ ] to me or something terrible
i'd be like
get out you get out of here taking the
time
to make a fake account to stalk you
stalk you go through the
exes you're following who you're liking
you know
we care well we actually got questioned
by one of our listeners
just friends with benefit's work and i
think no and i will shaking his head now
and i think no
i've never done it i've never been in
any way
can you speak like keira knightley for
like this next whole segment maybe
don't do that to her just like a little
bit because i i gassed you up about
what's really right here
you know it's all here it's in the face
love it's really honestly i do think
they can be friends
thank you honestly that was like i don't
even care about the rest of the segment
yeah no problem olivia oh my god um
so cysteine said that this is something
we can all talk about and i feel like
every
girl and guy can relate to and it is
body image especially i think
since we're all on social media it is
something that we
look at a lot more closely i think than
other people since we are
getting called out for our weight or the
way we look in clothes
or if we're doing workouts if we're not
doing workouts what we're eating for not
eating and
it can really catch up to you i feel
like have you had those experiences like
how is your body image
with social media youtube yeah i mean
it's
it's definitely um it's hard i mean
it's hard for everyone i don't think
i've met a person that i know like a
girl
even guys that don't have some sort of
kind of disordered
image of their body or because we're
constantly looking at other people and
comparing you know and
um it's hard for me too because like i
grew up naturally
small i was like born early have always
just been tiny
and i love working out just for feeling
strong and eating healthy because i want
to and
it gets hard sometimes because i used to
post a lot more like what i eat in a day
and like work out with me or even in
photos right people's bodies sometimes
are just naturally like that and i'll
get comments and dms being like you're
anorexic you look so bad you need to eat
like
you shouldn't be working out and it's
it's hard because i'm like but this is
my body this is how it was made i don't
know what to do i
just like the comments of someone saying
oh you look fat just calling someone
anorexic is
just as horrible as anything so it's
how much of that do you really like take
it and like take it to heart
i mean for a while i i just kind of
stopped doing those videos like as much
as i wanna like people
for some reason wanna see a what i eat
in a day i just can't bring myself to
make one because i'm like i can't
support it because if it's gonna in some
way make someone feel bad about their
body then like
i don't want to do that it definitely
takes a toll though because you know
i'll
be feeling good in my body and posting a
swimsuit picture and someone's like your
ribs are out you look
bad like you look disgusting you need
help and it's like that's just how my
ribs are
like i don't know it's hard to have
someone always like there's always
people who are gonna be there commenting
on
your body on what you're eating what
you're doing everyone has to have an
opinion and
to feel superior i don't know why no
it's true
something's so prevalent in social media
right now everyone has to shove their
opinion down their throat
it's really hard though because i admire
that because it's really hard to not
take what people's opinions are of you
and to actually apply them because i
know that when i was living in new york
and i was trying to model what are you
cracking up about you
what up you did good champ can we talk
about what a fail that was oh my god
anyway so i was i was
i was living when you started lose
something yeah that was a fat l but
anyway
my agents were like well you need to
lose weight and then you'll book the job
and i felt like okay i was already
you know fairly skinny for what i was
comfortable with and i was like okay i'm
gonna
you know work out and i met my my goal
weight which was really their goal
weight
and i realized i was like okay um still
not booking anything
and this is the unhappiest i've ever
been and since then it was like it gave
you some sort of like
it gave me some sort of weird body
dysmorphia because i was like okay i'm
never gonna be good and you're sitting
in a room
with these women who are like paper thin
and you look at them in the campaigns
and you're like they are the perfect
woman as like unfortunately that's how
you know this world depicts people it's
like
i have to say the industry now with
modeling is a little bit more accepting
of all body types yeah we'll give them
that
but i think it's just coming up yeah
recently
it was horrible and i i know that you
have such a terrible experience with it
too because
i realized i took a step back and i was
like okay this actually
isn't good for me and i feel sick and i
feel sad and i feel tired all the time
it's really hard to to remember too that
you're looking at these girls
like holy [ __ ] they're perfect it's
photoshopped it's airbrushed it's
lighting it's this it's done even the
girls on instagram today it's so crazy
when you see them in person you're like
oh it's it's the most insane thing is
that i've been the craziest thing like
moving from texas to la and then seeing
people used to probably follow and you
meet them you're like oh they're
not like that amazing i mean they're so
pretty but you're like
no it's like such a difference like as
bad as this sounds like i
love seeing those like those celeb face
like instagram accounts that show the
difference because it's just insane like
how much people photoshop themselves and
yeah and do that yeah like why
like i don't i know it's like don't
touch anything it's kind of sad because
you see even the people that you look up
to and they're like
making their waist even thinner than
what i was like oh i want that waist and
then you see them like
going back and forth with the editing
tool i'm like it just goes to the show
it just goes to show that it's not just
a singular struggle
it's everybody and that's what i mean
like every girl that i've ever met
in la has some sort of disorder view
towards
eating towards working out whatever it
is i think it gets more prevalent though
when you're going from even
la or new york because you see a lot of
these people that are really in the
industry and so their whole job is to
kind of keep up their appearance
and to be beautiful yeah we really do
live in like some la la land because
everyone in los angeles is just
beautiful like seriously i didn't really
get into the thing like the industry and
figure that out until i was a senior and
no i was a software in college and i
have a career body like i've boobs and
butt like sorry
i do not i just i cannot relate i could
be the boobs and butt of the group
um but when we got the golden globes we
were booking all these jobs and there
were a lot of like
runway stuff too and i was like this is
insane and we were getting put in these
giant campaigns
and i'll i kid you not like i never
really had
that much of an like body issue i never
like really saw myself really confident
i was pretty confident
when i got into this it was a whirlwind
change like you can ask christine
every single shoot they would put me in
extra large clothes like
bag it's kind of funny to be honest but
like it was almost insane because they
looked at your body and they're like
she's triple xl and you're like yeah i'm
sick
and they would put me in baggy clothes
i'm like okay they're covering my body
i'm like okay let's go along with this
i'll try to make it good
and i remember i went to one show and we
were kind of late to it but that they
were giving us like the last the litter
of like clothes that they had left um
they're giving all the good ones the
real models but they were zipping me up
in this size zero dress
and they couldn't speak english and so i
can kind of tell that they're like
[ __ ] like that they couldn't zip this up
and
i was starting like to tear up i'm like
okay this is so embarrassing they
brought the designer over and he
literally goes
ugh seriously he's fine we gotta like
fix this and have it she doesn't fit in
it and i
i literally like i've never had i i i
right now and i'm never speechless and
it really just threw me off i'm like
this is so wrong if i'm getting this
stuff and i'm like really not a real
model
imagine like what other people are
experiencing even like the models that
are really thin yeah probably like get
called out for maybe not being thin
enough i'm like it's so wrong
it's awful like don't make someone feel
bad about that i don't know like cece
remembers that it's taking me a while
like now i'm more confident about it but
2016 and it yeah bothers you today yeah
i mean sometimes i put on clothes i'm
like oh god am i
my boob's too big but you have to like
remind yourself i think that's the
hardest y'all both got beautiful ass
bodies let me tell you thank you
no but i'm the same i'll put on clothes
some days and i'm like
don't wear this you know i just makes me
do you do something to like
make yourself feel better about yourself
is there anything against parties
i love love like dancing in my room that
always gets me in a better mood it's
just like putting on music and just
dancing especially with my new cat like
just pick them up and force them to
dance yeah and the best i think the best
quote i've ever heard was
no one cares what you look like oh yeah
no everyone is so
that's the biggest thing my friend emma
has told me all the time
when i'm like anxious or whatever she's
like dude everyone's
way too busy focusing on themselves like
no one gives a [ __ ] what you're wearing
what you look like i mean they do but
you know what i mean like
yeah and then they're like they're going
back to like worrying about themselves
like oh what if i got bo i don't know
like they're always wearing this
okay so we have a fun little game
playing a game
all right we're going to play a word
association game okay okay so these are
the rules basically i'm going to say a
word you're going to say the first word
that comes to your mind okay
don't give up too much time to think are
you ready i'm nervous
all right here we go one and away
we go skin tight
cat dog big and small
i'm just going up and down come on all
right all right i'm focusing
okay tick tock oh addison right
not your baddest oh henry
your cat look
okay lips filler
oh happy oh
not a word i want to be happy
sometimes i don't want to be happy all
right
blood dark dance party
fake tits that's the first thing i
thought
pink dildo
[Laughter]
absolutely date it was scary
funny me actor
also hopefully me gross
me sexy
not me you guys
women powerful [ __ ] yeah
classic uh like sixties
i like that good job
half of those dancers
and we are back with another segment of
unsolicited advice and i'm just going to
rephrase what our rules
are roar
i'm going to restart
[Laughter]
and it is you guys have to go to apple
podcast
write your unsolicited device question
give us that good five stars
write that nice review and we will
answer your question just like we are
now because some people followed the
rules yeah thank you guys for actually
the ones that did it thank you yeah
honestly real ones we love a rule
okay this is from brooke with an
underscore a lot of them and another e
so brookie
brookie let's get it i have a question
what do you do when you feel burned out
recently i've tried to switch up my
schedule and make my workspace fun for
school by decorating for christmas
i'm a senior in high school working from
home and sometimes it's tough to stay
motivated
in that as well as in my creative life i
love to paint
um i love art and i would just love to
know what you guys do when you feel like
unmotivated and burnt out thanks
brookfield i used to get burnt out all
the time really bad because i wouldn't
be able to notice and then it would be
like
one day i'd just be like oh my god i'm
so exhausted i'm gonna literally have a
panic attack i need to
and then i would shut down for like
three weeks and it would take me a while
so i think
learning um you know what helps you get
out of it
and learning to stop yourself before you
get burnt out like
learning to take a break and like do
things that will distract you i know
it's a little bit hard especially with
school and online right now
um what did you used to do to like
unplug oh i just
you know i would make sure that i'm
getting enough sleep first of all taking
care of yourself is such a big part of
it of like making sure you're physically
and mentally okay or else
it's not gonna work yeah but like just
you know taking time for yourself every
day whatever that is if it's like if you
want to take a nap which is what i do
great if you want to like yeah
go for a walk anything to kind of just
resetting yourself and be like okay this
is okay
i can take it like have a go-to i love
that you know
yeah my my go-to i would say is i like
to when i
feel good sort of on the outside i feel
good inside
as um as shallow as that sounds no it's
not i think when i do have time like i
like to self-care so i'll do like a hair
mask or i'll do a facial or
i'll do a body scrub and i'll put on
like trash reality tv and i'll just be
like okay these are my 30 minutes
i'm going to watch this episode and i'm
just going to feel really good and yeah
because sometimes when you watch i find
that sometimes when you watch something
that isn't stimulating at all it's like
your brain can sort of just turn it off
so it's good just to like disconnect so
yeah do some self-care
so normally when i am starting to feel
burnt out i think the best way
especially when i was during like during
school time was to make a schedule i
think that having coveted an online
school it gets really chaotic and
there's really no set schedule anymore
and you can just be working for hours
and hours just staring at your computer
not really moving i think if you sit
down right out
okay i have school from eight to three i
have this amount of hours before dinner
i'm going to do
art for an hour 30 minutes anything just
to separate it and prioritize like the
school as much as
your creative activity but i mean
honestly i think just always have faith
that everything's just kind of kind of
it's going to work itself out the way it
needs to you know and like stressing to
a certain amount it's it's
what's the point you know like yeah we
stress over things but sometimes it's
like okay we can kind of let this go a
little bit because
it's it's going to happen or it's not
it'll pass like
what's the point of worrying about
something when you don't know if it's
going to happen or what's the outcome
it's like
you're just creating a [ __ ] show for
yourself right you know amen
olivia thank you for coming on welcome
thank you thank you thanks for having me
just can't we have the best time at our
wedding oh i can tell she tells me you
guys olivia and i get weekly dinners if
you liked her on the podcast we'll bring
her back if you didn't like her we'll
still bring her back i'm gonna get
things
we'll have our dinner story we should
have talked about that one
oh yeah we got stuff she's coming back
yeah why don't you uh plug all your
socials
oh um it's just literally my name it's
at olivia royer
happy thanksgiving y'all bye
that's it that's how you end it and see
bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts
at sophia stallone and at sistine
stallone and be sure to follow the show
at unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week
you